vamos a hacer un ejercicio
quiero que en este momento cierren los
ojos
los estoy viendo cierren los ojos
piensen en la primera vez que vivieron
un acoso sexual
piense en cuántos años tenían
dónde estaban
con quien estaban
como se sintieron en ese momento
y ahora la siguiente pregunta es
fueron la persona que vivió el acoso o
la persona que perpetró el acoso
pueden abrir los ojos
la primera vez que yo vivía una cosa
sexual tenía ocho años en esta niña
mis padres habían salido de vacaciones y
teníamos un vecino que vivía justamente
enfrente que todos los domingos jugaba
fútbol con mi papá no era una persona
muy cercana a la familia pero sí era
alguien que yo veía todos los domingos y
que además me conocía desde que nací mis
padres se van de vacaciones y mi abuela
se queda nuestro cuidado
este señor también se hizo amigo de mi
abuela y entonces ese día llega toca la
puerta y pues para mí era alguien
conocido simplemente pues lo dejé pasar
en cuanto me preguntó si estaba mi
abuela a los pocos minutos no sé cómo
pero tengo este hombre atrás de mí
pasando sus manos por mi cuerpo mientras
me repite una y otra vez qué bonita niña
eres
recuerdo perfecto
sus labios en mejillas sus labios
húmedos recuerdo perfecto su barba que
me picaba el cuello y recuerdo ver su
barba
no recuerdo que sucedió después el
siguiente recuerdo es estar parada entre
él y mi abuela y mi abuela saludándolo
con mucho gusto y yo decía no se da
cuenta no se da cuenta que estoy a punto
de llorar que algo acaba de pasar aquí
durante días tuve esto en la cabeza
porque pues mi abuela no se ha dado
cuenta y por lo tanto yo no dije nada lo
tuve en la cabeza y dije fue mi culpa
fue mi culpa porque lo dejé pasar a la
casa fue mi culpa porque yo en ningún
momento le dije esto no me parece
adecuado fue mi culpa como niña de 8
años tal vez con otras palabras me
repetía que fue mi culpa
me quedé callada y no lo dije durante
años probablemente pasaron 12 años para
que yo contara esto a mi madre ya mi
padre por situaciones externas al acoso
sexual y ellos no podían creer que esto
sucediera en su casa que esto le haya
sucedido a su hija de 8 años a quien
cuidaron bastante
me gustaría decirles que este es un caso
aislado que esto fue algo que me sucedió
a mí no sucede a más niñas en el país
pero no es así
ella es fabiola cuando fabio la tenía
nueve años fue a la papelería con su
prima que tenía más o menos la misma
edad y el señor de la papelería con el
pretexto de sentir la tela de la playera
empezó a tocar a fabiola y le empezó a
tocar los pezones hizo lo mismo con su
prima las dos salieron de la papelería y
nunca hablaron del tema
esta es la fabiola de 9 años
ella es sofía cuando sofía tenía también
nueve años su padrastro debía llevarla a
todos los jueves a la escuela en vez de
llevarla a la escuela la desvestía y le
decía que iban a jugar un juego que era
solo de ellos y que su madre no debía
enterarse porque se iba enojar la tocaba
y la forzaba a tocarlo
este de sofía a la edad de su primera
cosa
ella es belinda cuando belinda cumplió
15 años aprendió a que todas las noches
tenía que cerrar su puerta con candado
al menos poner el seguro porque todas
las noches entraba su padrastro y la
forzaba a tocarlo
esta es la edad aquí estaba linda a los
15 años belinda y sofía son hermanas
cuando sofía le cuenta belinda los
acosos que está viviendo por parte de su
padrastro
belinda decide contarle a la familia y
la familia la culpa a ella porque si
ello hubiera dicho que su padrastro
entraba a su cuarto pues entonces no
hubiera pasado nada sofía
a la fecha hay quien culpa belinda de
los acosos que sufrió sofía y a la fecha
su madre que no les creyó vive con su
padrastro
ella es rocío
cuando rocío tenía 6 años de edad su tío
entró a la casa borracho y le repetía
una y otra vez te amo mientras la fue
acorralando en la cocina
los yo no recuerdo mucho el siguiente
recuerdo que tiene es estar en la
regadera tallando se lo más fuerte
posible porque se sentía sucia el cuerpo
le dolía
en la regadera empezó a repetir una
efeméride que tenía que decir al
siguiente lunes en la escuela a la fecha
de rocío se sabe es efeméride porque su
cuerpo su mente más bien generó un
mecanismo de defensa en el que tomó el
recuerdo de que rocío fue violada a los
seis años y lo sustituyó con esta
efeméride
este es rocío de 6 años
ella es karen cuando caen tenía 13 años
y regresaba de la secundaria un señor la
seguía todos los días
karen se lo dijo a su madre y su madre
dijo no te apures que son un loquito
seguramente un día este señor acorraló a
karen en un terreno baldío la toco y la
fuerza o besarlo por suerte la dejó ir y
nunca lo volvió a ver bueno más bien no
lo vio dentro de los próximos dos años
cuando karen tenía 15 años este señor
regresó y todos los días se sentaba
enfrente de casa de karen hasta que un
día decidieron llamar a la policía y la
policía llegó y dijo que bueno que lo
encontraron porque este señor tiene
denuncias de violación
esta es karen a la edad de 13 años
también me gustaría decir estas son sólo
historias que exclusivas pero no lo son
el 24 de abril de 2016 salió este
hashtag mi primer acoso de ahí se
generaron 78 mil tweets que de acuerdo
con un estudio de la unam el 93% son de
mujeres en estos tuits las mujeres
contaban sus primeros acosos cómo se
sentían cuántos años tenían dónde
estaban quién había perpetrado el acoso
esa noche yo me quedé leyendo los tweets
y estaba atónita no podía creer que esto
sucediera en el país me identificaba con
muchos y otros me sorprendían
cuatro cosas me sorprendieron cinco la
primera es que eso sería a temprana edad
la mayoría de acuerdo con la unam que
hizo un estudio de todos estos tweets la
mayoría de los acosos sexuales sucedían
entre los 6 y 11 años el primer acoso
sexual es decir siquiera antes de que se
llegue a la adolescencia
en la edad más común eran los 8 años la
siguiente fue la culpa la mayoría de las
mujeres al igual que yo sentían culpa
porque algo a bien habían sentían que
algo habían hecho para merecer ese acoso
sexual
los acosos fueron perpetrados también en
su mayoría en el primer círculo es decir
por amigos amigos de la familia
familiares tíos padrastros y hasta
hermanos y padres
la siguiente es que sucedía en sus
espacios cotidianos muchas de las
mujeres denunciaron que su primer acoso
sucedió en la escuela y en su casa como
fue mi caso
y finalmente
el silencio
muchas de ellas se habían quedado en
silencio durante años al igual que yo
pasaron décadas para que pudieran hablar
este acoso sexual muchas otras era la
primera vez que hablaban de este acoso
sexual
y entonces ese día yo dije que qué está
sucediendo porque los hombres están
tocando a niñas tan pequeñas oa niñas no
fin y entonces dije bueno tal vez es una
cuestión de edad y me gustaría decirles
que sí que es una cuestión de edad pero
tampoco lo es
después de se acostó después de mi
primer acoso a los 10 yo nadaba
y aprendí que no debía acercarme al
salvavidas porque el salvavidas tocaba a
las niñas entonces no lo hacía
a los 13 de repente mi cuerpo se
convirtió en una canasta de basketball
porque mis compañeros jugaban a ver
quién podía atinar un papelito de una
bolita de papel a mi escote
a los 14 empecé a escuchar piropos en la
calle de repente mi cuerpo había
cambiado y los primeros en darse cuenta
eran desconocidos eran hombres que me
veían por partes
a los 15 escuché el primer piropo que me
marcó
chiquita con de oro te lo quiero
poner entre las tetas
nunca había dicho ese acostumbro salta
hoy es la primera vez que lo hago
los años pasaron ingenieros mecanismos
de defensa empecé a caminar enojada en
la calle empecé a mirar a la gente
directamente si tenía que ir a algún
lado y ves el lugar con pasos firmes
inclusive estoy segura como muchas
mujeres aquí empecé a caminar con las
llaves en la mano
pero ninguno de esos mecanismos funciona
porque la cosa sexual está presente en
todos lados hace algunos años ya en mis
veintes es una de mis parejas tuvo sexo
conmigo cuando yo seguía dormida es
decir sin mi consentimiento el espacio
más íntimo tampoco era seguro
y a los 26 gane un premio de periodismo
nacional lo logre por fin era reconocida
por mi cerebro por fin
y el discurso de aceptación y se acercó
a mí un periodista y me dijo si esto
logras a los 26 no quiero saber qué vas
a lograr dentro de diez o quince años
vas a ser una mujer que nadie pueda
parar
y ese había sido el halago halago más
grande que me habían dado en mi carrera
profesional o probablemente en mi vida
esa noche hubo una fiesta para celebrar
el premio y durante esa misma fiesta ese
mismo hombre que me dio ese halago me
tocó sin mi consentimiento
cualquier halago que me pudo haber dado
se derrumbó
cualquier premio que tenías en ese
momento si era nada de repente regresé a
hacer
esa grieta de ocho años con miedo y con
dudas y sin saber qué estaba sucediendo
creo que
si preguntara en este momento cuántas
mujeres han vivido un acoso sexual en su
vida más del 90% de las mujeres aquí
levantaría en la mano cualquier tipo de
acoso ya sea un piropo o hasta llegar a
una violación
no es algo que vivís solamente yo es
algo que aprendemos las mujeres todos
los días y en mi caso yo a los 8 aprendí
que no estaba segura en mi casa a los 12
que no estaba segura en la escuela a los
14 que no estaba segura en la calle a
los 23 24 aprendí que no estaba segura
con mi pareja y a los 26 aprendí que
aquellas personas que se dedican a
visibilizar y visibilizar las
injusticias también las reproducen
no es un caso aislado todas hemos
aprendido algo similar
y aquí tenemos una problemática que
estamos viendo pero hay cosas que nos
duelen tanto o nos incomodan tanto que
preferimos no verlas
pero es labor nuestra arreglar esto es
labor nuestra solucionar esta
problemática y entonces quiero regresar
a los cinco puntos que llamaron mi
atención
el primero que suceda a temprana edad
tenemos que hablar con nuestras niñas y
niños y enseñarles que su cuerpo es suyo
decirle a las niñas tu cuerpo es tuyo y
nadie lo puede tocar más que tú decirle
a los niños tu cuerpo es tuyo nadie lo
puede tocar más que tú pero además no
eres dueño de ningún otro cuerpo no
tienes derechos sobre ningún otro cuerpo
la culpa todas nos sentíamos culpables
pero en realidad no importa qué tan
pronunciados el escote o qué tan corta
sea la falda un acoso nunca es nuestra
culpa no fue mi culpa dejar entrar al
vecino no fue mi culpa llevarme bien con
mis compañeros no fue mi culpa acercarme
un colega ninguno de mis acosos fue mi
culpa
en realidad la culpa es de un sistema
que les enseñado a los hombres que
tienen derecho sobre nuestros cuerpos y
de los hombres que aprovechan ese
sistema
el siguiente es el primer círculo en
este momento vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio
quiero que voltean a ver si vienen con
alguien que volteen a ver a la persona
con la que vienen si no hagan también el
esfuerzo de voltear a ver a la persona
que está al lado de ustedes
en este momento se atreverían a tocar a
esa persona sin su consentimiento
probablemente no ahora después de haber
visto esa persona quiero que piense en
su cuerpo vale más o menos que el suyo
la pregunta esta es un poco ridícula
cierto los cuerpos valen exactamente
igual no tendríamos por qué estar
pensando en ponerle valor a un cuerpo no
tenemos derecho sobre la otra persona
somos seres humanos y eso nos hace
iguales sin importar nuestra edad o
nuestro sexo
entonces una vez que entendimos esto me
parece que es sencillo entender que no
importa si conozco esta persona o qué
tan cercana es a mí o si es una persona
completamente desconocida no tengo
derecho sobre su cuerpo
la siguiente los espacios cotidianos
cuántas veces hemos visto a un hombre
tirar un piropo a una mujer en la calle
un chiflido algo seguro lo han visto han
dicho algo
tendremos que bueno que por allá alguien
dijo algo pero tendemos a no decir nada
a quedarnos callados y calladas como
pretendemos eliminar el acoso sexual de
nuestro espacio más privado si ni
siquiera nos lo eliminamos en el ámbito
público
finalmente el silencio
tenemos que romper el silencio es
necesario que hablemos esto de estos
temas aunque nos incomoden y cómo lo
vamos a hacer a través de la empatía
con las historias conectamos con las
historias nos identificamos con la gente
y no sé si recuerdan a fabiola pero
cuando fabiola ya tenía sus 20 años
estaba haciendo prácticas profesionales
y llegó a las prácticas llorando y
entonces su jefe preguntó fabiola qué
pasó bueno pues saviola iba caminando en
la calle cuando un coche se orilló salió
una mano y le dio una nalgada fabiola
lloraba de impotencia y de tristeza
se lo contó al jefe el jefe la
tranquilizó y el día siguió
al siguiente día llegó el jefe y dijo
fabiola te debo una disculpa
la biela se quedó sumamente confundida
porque tú tendrías que disculparte por
la nalgada de ayer pero yo estoy segura
que no fuiste tú y entonces el jefe
contestó no fui yo ayer pero cuando yo
era joven solía hacer eso mucho porque
me parecía gracioso me parecía pues una
nalgada ella jamás me quedé pensando en
la mujer que se quedaba parada en la
calle y que alguien le había tocado sin
su consentimiento y te pido una disculpa
por todas esas mujeres que llegué a
tocar entonces a través de las historias
podemos romper ese silencio
en este momento ya que identificamos un
poco más cómo se siente un acoso sexual
quiero que volvamos a hacer el ejercicio
cierren los ojos
piensen en el primer acoso sexual que
vivieron
como se sintieron donde estaban con
quien estaban cuántos años tenían
y ahora piensen de nuevo fueron la
persona que acosó o fueron la persona
que fue víctima de ese acoso
abran los ojos
esto no es una cuestión sólo de hombres
o sólo de mujeres es una cuestión de
todas y todos nosotros y entonces mi
propuesta es mujeres hablemos de
nuestras historias hagamos los no
hagamos las nuestras porque si no les
hablamos esas historias se quedan
enterradas y entonces si convertimos
esas historias en nuestras rompemos el
silencio y en vez de ser víctimas
empezamos a actuar en contra del acoso
sexual hombres amigo date cuenta
tus acciones tienen repercusiones y lo
que sea que le hagas a otra persona
tiene repercusiones más allá del acto en
ese momento las mujeres no son un objeto
las mujeres somos igual que ustedes
somos humanos entonces se han perpetrado
un acoso
acéptenlo escuchen también a sus
hermanas a sus madres a sus amigas
escuchen en las mujeres y gené y generen
empatía platiquen lo con sus amigos
detengan acosos de otros hombres esto es
algo que podemos hacer entre todos y
todas
hay dos cosas que si las nombras
se rompen
la primera es el silencio
y la segunda es el acoso sexual
rompamos el acoso sexual rompamos el
silencio gracias
[Aplausos]